how are you feeling about being evicted
now that you have had some time to think
about it
uh
of course i wish that i was still in
there but also i find myself really at
peace with my experience i think that i
played as hard as i could in there i
left without
really any major regrets and i'm just
really proud of the game that i played
um and really happy that i had the
opportunity to play as well
um
and i'm looking forward to being a juror
and voting for one of these people to
become a heck of a lot richer
your conversation with tiffany when she
explained why she was nominating you was
very emotional what was going through
your mind at that time
at that time i was dealing with so much
inner conflict it's a really complex
issue and i felt complex emotions then
and honestly i still feel some complex
emotions but also what i really really
felt was so proud of tiffany and so much
love for tiffany that this was what she
was deciding with that she was going
with this and of course i wish i was
still in there but at the end of the day
i just absolutely adore tiffany and i'm
really proud of her for sticking with
her guns
is there something you wish you had done
differently in the game
ah
it's hard i i somewhat i wish that i had
formed more one-on-one connections a lot
of my alliances i was in i was also in
it with tiffany that said i think i
played a decent social game i think that
i did have a lot of friends in there um
maybe i wish that with the coin of
destiny before i played it i'd done some
more information gathering and i try to
make some deals for myself
but
i didn't know if i was gonna win i
didn't know who else was gonna play and
i was just so focused on keeping
tiffany's nominees the same
i don't really have any major regrets at
all
how would you describe your big brother
experience and would you play again
my bb experience was definitely hectic i
tried to flip so many boats i tried to
align with so many people they were all
moving plates i was juggling them all or
whatever that saying is
um but
it was really really really fun and i
cried way more than i thought i was
gonna cry in there and i formed deeper
friendships than i thought was going to
be possible when you're competing for a
ton of money um but
absolutely
if they asked me the day after finale to
play right away i would do it it's a
game that i absolutely adore and i had
so much fun doing i would come back in a
heartbeat
you